will tom bergeron go back to the
ballroom welcome neve shulman who is an
amazing dancer by the way
thank you congratulations you finished
as the runner up to caitlyn bristow
right that's right
were you robbed well look there's an
electoral college voter we'll get into
that we'll get into that
we'll get into that later but first tom
talks about a return to dancing
[Applause]
there's an old saying that the show must
go on
well not when it comes to returning to
dancing with the stars
tom pretty much ruled that out saying
quote when people say
i'm not going to watch until you're back
i say well there's really no until
this train has left the station in his
first interview since being fired and
replaced by tyra banks
tom told tv guide magazine quote i don't
hold it against anybody if they still
watch
which couples will take home the
mirrorball trophy
this week tyra said she's looking
forward to returning next season as host
though there is no comment from abc et
spoke with her just
after the finale where she addressed her
critics
yes there was change but the change
meant a hell of a lot of big rating
so in the end you know this is a
business and that's what matters and
change is a good thing
did you ever hear from tom at all about
how this year yeah
or anything no i haven't had a personal
conversation with him but i still
feel i'm feeling the deaf already okay
you know who else we're feeling some
things in the ballroom hi baby
you're not ready for that krishell
styles and dancing pro kyo mastepe
they made their new romance instagram
official with a cuddly selfie and a
sweat session
there it is our source says the new
couple have been together for a couple
of weeks
they're very into each other but it's
not super serious
of course the 39 year old joined the
show after her sudden split from x
this is us star justin hartley
completely single i'm excited to mingle
our et source says the couple quote
haven't been shy about showing pda in
front of
other dancing with the stars cast
members and everyone has been so
supportive
of their relationship